now moving on to conversate 13 here we
go and I see all those in favor of combi
site 13
thank you and all those against big
cheers for the folks against
[Applause]
silence what's she going to announce
sorry I thought it was one when Jenny
said something else yes that that was
lost lost so another victory for that's
a big blow for those who pick the throw
remainders another victory from the
support and a lot of tears as you can
hear there you can hear a pin drop
during that vote communal tension in the
hall there are four for a card and 14
John this is supporting the Corbin
motion in effect is it yes indeed I
think there's a call for a card vote
let's wait and see what happens
[Applause]
korban supporters cheering and singing
his name was a call for a car vote I'm
not sure if the chair is allowing it
can't can can we sit down I know that's
a difficult sorry
can I can I just look whichever way I go
with this I'm going to be in trouble
with some people in my view it was
carriage it was in my view it was
carriage he said it was lost I thought
all right sorry listen I'm getting it
that it was lost sorry sorry yes she
said it was lost a minute ago and whilst
I accept we had a number of perverts
yesterday it was closer than what this
was it's a very difficult it isn't it it
we have nothing in our Standing Orders
our Constitution which some organizers
patients have where if there's a number
of people calling for it we can do that
so it's the decision the decision has to
be as I called it that it was lost and
that's very difficult looks as though
she's rejected calls for a cart boat
there something in the whole understand
the difficulties we've had a really good
debate we've we've respected each
other's points of view and at the point
where you know I can if if it wasn't
clear Adam asked for a car
conference this is one of the most
important decisions that the Labour
Party will take this decade and I think
we deserve a card vote here
we have already we have already heard we
have already heard from delegates we've
already heard from delegates that the
unions actually are quite split on this
unison are a favorite of Congress at 13
you know you but again I think it's
impossible to tell from the floor
[Music]
democracy in action
a real route going on here as you can
hear a call for a card boat there let's
see what the ruling is delegates
delegates delegates no absolutely please
sit down and to the last person you can
see my lanyard I'm a member of unison
apart a former president and they will
expect me to do what's right and if it
was carried I would have said that had
it and it was lost and they will accept
that as well she seems to be sticking
[Applause]
the mattock seems here I'm pretty
extraordinary scenes aren't they for you
know something that is so important for
the party well that was a point that was
being made by the person who demanded a
card boat the strength to leave and I
want this to be right with each other
because the most important thing from
any of us is a Labour government to deal
with all the issues that we've talked
about this week so I am now moving on to
conversate 14 no I'm not going back to
that we've had the discussion I know
you'll be upset no I'm moving on just
ruling out schools for a table a lot of
people have a hold out like it can I see
all those in favor no I'm not going to
be bullied and shouted out and all the
rest of it the decisions being made